Guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend.
Hallo, ich bin Volkan Baran und bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne diese Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ja.
Ich bin der Herr der Söderst.
Mein Name ist Klaus Werner.
Herr Werner, können Sie Ihre Nahtname buchen?
Wir haben eine Aufnahmegespräch mit Emyl Richard.
Herr Werner, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
Und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Am 17.04.1993.
17.04.1993.
Ich kann nicht gut zuhören, aber 1990.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
78 Kilogramm.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt?
Ein Hausarzt? Ja.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist der Doktor.
Doktor, wie heißt er?
Walenski.
Können Sie buchstabieren?
Nein, kann ich nicht genau.
Walenski mit VWD.
Ich bin der Doktor.
Was hat Sie zu uns geführt?
Ich habe seit 6 Wochen Schmerzen.
Ich habe sie in meinem rechten Knie gelenkt.
Die Schmerzen gehen in meinen rechten Knie nicht weg.
Ich strahle sie ein bisschen aus bis zu meinem Unterchenkel.
Die Schmerzen sind belastungshappläglich.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich habe.
Bei Bewegung oder Belastung?
Verschlechtert oder behindert?
Ja, verschlägt.
Aber auch danach, wenn ich eine bestimmte Strecke laufe
und es so, dass es danach weh tut.
Sie haben mir gesagt, seit 6 Wochen
haben wir am rechten Knie gelenkt eine Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Unterchenkel aus.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skalaphone 1 bis 10?
Wenn es bei einem leicht unerträglichen Schmerz ist.
Wenn es schlimm wird, ist es nicht dauernd schlimm.
Aber wenn es schlimm wird, ist es etwa 6.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ich meine Poker, Brennende oder Siehende Schmerzen.
Was können Sie sagen?
Ich würde zwischen Wochen der Schmerzen in meinem Knie
und auch Ziehende Schmerzen beschreiben.
Beides verpochtet und manchmal bei Belastung
zieht es in meinen Unterchenkel rein.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind nicht immer da, oder?
Genau.
Wenn ich keine Belastung habe, die ganze Zeit sitze.
Manchmal kommt es zu einer Ruhe.
Manchmal tut es nicht weh.
Dann fange ich an zu laufen und dann kommt der Schmerz wieder.
Wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen?
Plötzlich oder langsam?
Ich habe in einem Fußball-Turnier teilgenommen.
Aber ich habe den ganzen Fußballspiel gespielt.
Am nächsten Tag haben die Schmerzen begonnen.
Am Wochenende haben wir Fußball gespielt.
Am Sonntag wollte ich zur Uni gehen.
Es ging dann nicht.
Es ging schon, aber ich musste die Ibuprofen einnehmen.
Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, das hilft mir.
Ich habe die Ibuprofen 400 oder 600 Milligramm geholfen.
Ich hatte 400 Apotheke geholt.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Haben Sie Ihre Kniegelenkel irgendwo gestoßen?
Nein, eigentlich kann ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich verletzt.
Aber das war nach dem Spiel.
Das war das auffällige.
Aber das war nicht am nächsten Tag.
Ich hatte Schmerzen.
Ich habe die Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Ich habe die Ibuprofen aufgenommen.
Haben Sie eine Rötung, Schwellung oder Überwärmung gemacht?
Eine leichte Überwärmung im Innenseite des Kniegelenkens.
Ein rechter Kniegelenk?
Ein rechter Kniegelenk innenseitig.
Ein bisschen überwärmt.
Es fühlt sich warmer.
Es ist nicht ganz warm und rot.
Es fühlt sich manchmal warmer.
Wie weit können Sie laufen, ohne diese Schmerzen zu bekommen?
Ich würde sagen, 200 Meter laufen.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen mehr als 200 Meter.
Aber wann fängt es dann an, die zu tun?
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Herzrasen gemacht?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, was diese Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Aus Ibuprofen und Ruhe?
Ja.
Außer, dass ich Schuhe oder Ibuprofen habe, weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie sonst noch etwas hinzufügen?
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein.
Ich bin interessiert, was das ist.
Wie bitte?
Ich kann nicht genau sagen,
wie wir diese Aufnahmegespräche zu Ende führen.
Dann ein paar Diagnostiken durchführen,
um Ihre Diagnose genau zu stellen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich habe noch ein paar Unterrichts,
um Ihre Diagnose genau zu stellen.
Dann kann ich genau das sagen.
Nun kann ich leider nichts sagen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ist gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Sturrgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Schlafprobleme?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Manchmal mache ich, wenn ich viel unterwegs war,
manchmal auf, weil das Knie mit dem anderen Knie,
wenn er sich berührt, tut es auch weh.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme, nur wegen den Schmacken.
Ich verstehe es nicht ganz genau.
Haben Sie Nachgewicht oder Schütterfrost bemerkt?
Nein.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Was meint ihr damit?
Ich meine, eine Zuckerkrankheit oder eine Art der Bluthochdruck?
Bluthochdruck?
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt oder operiert?
Ja, operiert wurde schon, da war ich neun Jahre alt.
Was operiert bei Ihnen?
Damals wurde mein Blender entnommen.
Und wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Sind Sie gegen Covid um die Kindheiterkrankungen geimpft?
Ja, also in meiner Kindheit hatte ich alle Impfungen bekommen
und ich bin auch gegenüber Covid mal erkrankt worden.
Und bin auch gebusteter geimpft, zusätzlich.
Aber schon länger her.
2020, September wurde ich krank.
Und halb Jahr später oder irgendwann danach hatte ich ne Impfung bekommen.
Zusätzlich.
Können Sie jetzt wiederholen? Ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen, aber...
Ja.
Vor zwei Jahren, ne, drei Jahren mittlerweile, war ich ca. vor drei Jahren an Corona erkrankt.
Sechs Monate später oder sieben, acht Monate später hatte ich noch mal eine Corona Impfung bekommen.
Ja, okay. Einmal Sie hatten Corona gehabt und dann einmal geimpft.
Genau, ich hatte Corona, also die Infektion durchgemacht.
Und ungefähr sechs, sieben Monate später wurde ich trotzdem noch mal geimpft.
Sechs Monate.
Und waren Sie im Letzte seit Ausland?
Ausland, ne.
Ich habe es vergessen, haben Sie im Letzte seit umgeworden, ab oder zu gehen, oder?
Ne.
Okay.
Und ne, nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente ein außer Ibuprofen?
Ne.
Okay.
Und haben Sie allergie in oda Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, also ich habe Penicillin allergie und gegenüber Dickler-Fernack habe ich vertragisch nicht um Verträglichkeit gegenüber Dickler-Fernack.
Wie reagieren Sie sich, wenn ein Penicillin oder Dickler-Fernack bekommen haben?
Bei Penicillin kriege ich Atemnot, weil mein Hals anschwillt.
Ich habe einen Blindarm operiert wurde, habe mir das Penicillin gegeben und da konnte ich schlecht atmen, seitdem darf ich das nicht mehr einnehmen.
Dickler-Fernack hatte ich mal irgendwann mal genommen, wo ich irgendwelche Schmerzen hatte und da hatte ich Durchfall und Magenschmerzen bekommen gehabt.
Habe ich nicht gut vertragen.
Okay.
Und Herr Wernawi, ist Ihr Familienstand, sind Sie verheiratet, oder?
Nein, ich lebe alleine, ich habe eine Freundin und bin nicht verheiratet.
Ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden, Sie leben mit Ihrer Freund, oder?
Nein, ich habe eine Freundin, Sie haben gefragt, ob ich verheiratet bin, ich bin nicht verheiratet, ich habe auch eine Freundin.
Leben Sie alleine, ich glaube.
Ab und zu bin ich bei meiner Freundin, ab und zu ist sie bei mir.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Kinder habe ich nicht, nee.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich ich studiere, mache gerade meinen Markter im Baujuniorwesen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie viel Stress?
Ja, das ist normal.
Ich arbeite noch nebenbei als Student, mal arbeiten, studieren, aber sonst nicht so besonders.
Nicht projekte, ich denke, das ist ein positiver Stress.
Okay.
Herr Werna, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Auf regelmäßig trinke ich kein Alkohol.
Ab und zu bei Gelegenheit, wenn irgend eine Feier ist oder Geburtstag, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Was trinken Sie bei Feierabend und wie viel trinken Sie, können Sie sagen?
Wie viel, was weiß ich.
Dann kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern, da bin ich dann besochen.
Okay, ich verstehe ganz genau.
Es ist halt eine Party, Feier und dann trinkt man, aber es ist nicht jedes Wochenende Party.
Sie sauren nicht die Flasche, ich glaube.
Ich werde eingeladen, oder irgendwo bin ich dann beim Feiern, aber es ist nicht so oft, ich gehe selten zu Feiern.
Gehe legendlich, das könnte ich mir sagen.
Herr Werna, ich muss eine Frage stellen, aber bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Diese Frage gehört zu einem vorständigen Anamnesegespräch.
Es bleibt unter uns, was Sie mir sagen.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Das war sehr schön.
Und treiben Sie Support?
Ich glaube, Sie spielen Fußball.
Also, Sie sind nicht in einem Verein mit Freunden öfter zusammen und organisieren irgendwelche Turniere.
Ich würde sagen, fast regelmäßig.
Aber ich glaube, Sie haben schon ein paar Jahre lang mit Freunden zusammengekommen.
Einmal in der Woche treppen wir uns, oder alle zwei Wochen, und spielen Fußball.
Aber an dem Wochenende war ein bisschen viel gewesen, da war ein Turnier gewesen, da habe ich mitgemacht.
Aber nicht in einem Verein.
Das ist so initiativ, müßig.
Als Amateur, ich glaube.
Okay.
Und Herr Werna, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, mein Eltern leben es.
Und leiden Sie an irgendetwas, chronische Erkrankungen?
Erkrankungen, was Sie vorhin gemeint haben mit Bluthoch.
Ja, mein Vater nimmt Medikamente wegen Bluthoch zurück.
Meine Mutter, sie nimmt Medikamente wegen der Schildrüse.
Schildrüse.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Und ist sie gesund?
Ja, die ist schümmert, die ist gesund.
Herr Werna, wenigstens Sie haben Sie richtig verstanden.
Sie haben seit sechs Wochen bei rechtsseitiger Poker und Sichernde aufgetreten.
Ich glaube, Sie haben nach einem Fußballspiel aufgetreten.
Und ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Dann sollen wir ein Röntgen veranlassen.
Nach den Befunden vorlegen, sprechen wir wieder darüber.
Hier gibt es eine Frage.
Kann ich gerne antworten?
Okay, wenn Sie eine Frage haben, eine Frage nicht.
Ja, das war mein erstes.
Deswegen bin ich ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie etwas übertreiben oder überlassen.
Alles gut.
Herr Kollege, ob Sie eine Frage haben?
Herr Kollege, ob Sie etwas übertreiben oder nicht?
Wir müssen nicht Türkisch sprechen.
Wir wollen nicht Türkisch sprechen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ende möglich.
Hier in Deutschland wird Deutsch gesprochen.
Ja, leider.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ich habe betroffen, meine Taubheitsgefühle, Kraftlosigkeit und so weiter.
Taubheitsgefühl habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie noch gefragt?
Sind Ihnen Taubheitsgefühle, Kraftlosigkeit oder Kraftlosigkeit aufgefallen?
Nein, es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie bemerkt oder haben Sie Missempfindungen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Können Sie mir genau bemerken, dass Ihre Schmerzen aufgetreten sind?
Wenn ich beurge, zum Beispiel beim Treppenlaufen, habe ich Schmerzen.
Das ist ja auch eine Beugung.
Wenn ich hier in der Luft sitze und meine Knie, Beuge und Strecke habe, habe ich keinen großen Schmerz.
Haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie Fußball spielen?
Ja, aber ich hatte früher solche Beschwerden.
Nicht, dass ich mich nicht so intensiv erinnere.
Herr Werner?
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass wenn Sie Ihre Beine hochheben oder aufheben, wird die Schmerz schlimmer?
Wenn ich meine Beine hochhebe, meinen Sie im Liegen?
Hochlage.
Wenn ich die hochlage, ist es schlimmer oder?
Nein, es ist kein Unterschied zwischen sitzen und hochlagern.
Können wir Arsatzgeschichte anfangen?
Für mich kein Problem.
Aber ich bin nicht sehr gut bei Arsatzgeschichte.
Ich bitte, versuchte.
Versuchen Sie es bitte.
Hallo Herr Doktor.
Hallo Herr Oberatz.
Ich habe eine neue Bege hier in der Klinik.
Ich habe einen neuen...
Ich bin der Kollege hier in der Klinik. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Foukambaran und ich bin Anfänger hier.
Wir haben nicht kennengelernt deswegen.
Kein Problem. Mein Name ist Müller, Oberarzt Müller.
Hallo Herr Dr. Müller, ich freue mich, kennen zu lernen.
Ja bitte ich auch. Dann schießen Sie mal los.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient, Herr Werner, ist ein 30-jähriger Patient,
der sich heute Abend bei uns in der Notaufnahme seit wegen seit sechs Wochen
aufgetretene Poker, Siehende und rechtseitige Klinge-Näckschmerzen
ohne Ausüterahlung vorgestellt hat.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen nach einem Fußballspielen aufgetreten seien
und beim Ruhe besser, bei Belastung oder Treppensteigen schlimmer geworden seien.
Zusätzlich teilt er mit, dass die Schmerzen sechs von zehn auf der Schmerzskala seien.
Sie haben ein Tablette Ibuprofen 400 mg eingenommen,
aber es hat ihm nur ein bisschen geholfen.
Hat er nur einmal eingenommen oder öfter?
Wenn er einen Schmerz hat, dann hat er bei Bedarf eingenommen.
Er erwähnt, dass er bei Betrofenestelle leichte Überwärmung und Rötung bemerkt habe.
Die Fragen nach ähnlichem vorherigen Beschwörden, Taubheitsgefühl,
Kribbendegefühl, Missempfindungen, Herzrasen, Atemnot,
wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Sie haben gute Appetit, sie haben keine Gewichtverlustprobleme.
Es wurde bei ihm mit neun Jahren eine Blindamentfernung durchgeführt.
Wie würde sie das medizinisch ausdrücken?
Appendectome. Der Patient wurde mit neun Jahren eine Appendectomie durchgeführt.
Er wurde mit neun Jahren Appendectomiert.
Ich wusste es nicht.
Kann ich es schreiben?
Ich kann es nicht.
Appendectomiert.
Er wurde mit neun Jahren Appendectomiert.
Können wir die andere Begriffe beengeln?
Scholezistomiert kann man auch sagen.
Oder eine Scholezistomiert durchgeführt kann man auch sagen?
Er habe einmal Covid-Gib, oder?
Erkrankung durchgemacht.
Er wurde mit Corona-Impfungen durchgeführt.
Er wurde nach der Erkrankung einmal geimpft.
Er hat eine Penicillin-Allergie und Diplofenac-Allergie gehabt.
Er hat eine Reaktion gegen Penicillin und Atemnot.
Er ist gegen Penicillin allergisch.
Er ist nicht traurig.
Er hat eine Unverträglichkeit gegen Penicillin.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Er trinkt regelmäßig Alkohol.
Er ist allein.
Er lebt alleine.
Er lebt alleine mit Freundenleben.
Er hat gesagt, dass er verheiratet ist.
Er wohnt alleine.
Er lebt mit Freundenleben.
Er ist ein Fußballfan.
Er studiert Bauingenieur.
Er lebt mit Freundenleben.
Er hat ein Schilderys-Problem.
Er ist ein Schilderys-Problem.
Er lebt mit Freundenleben.
Er hat einen Traum.
Er ist 30 Jahre alt.
Er hat eine Prellung.
Er hat eine Überwärmung und Rötung.
Er hat gesagt, dass er überwärmt ist.
Er ist am höchsten bei einem jungen Mensch.
Er hat Fußball gespielt.
Er hat gesagt, dass er in den Innenbereich ist.
30-jährigen. Was für eine Fraktur würde man, wenn überhaupt, kein Traum, es ist kein Traum.
Potorologisch. Ja genau, ein potorologischer Fraktur. Kann einer haben, vielleicht hat er einen.
Aber es gibt keine Gewichtverlust und B-Symphtomatik, deswegen.
Ja, es ist immer in der Unkulug, ich bin kein Unkuluge, aber gibt es in der Unkulugie
ein hundertprozentiger Nachweis, das jeder Nachtschweiß hat und also die B-Symphtomatik,
also muss man nicht haben, kann sein. Eine Züste sein, die im Knie ist, die dann einbricht,
ohne dass der Gewichtsverlust ist oder so, kann alles. Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr
gering, aber wenn es eine Fraktur ist, ohne Trauma, es ist eine pathologische oder eine
typologische Fraktur, weil er sehr stark ein Vitamin D-Mangel hat zum Beispiel.
Sein der Kind kann auch eine pathologische Fraktur machen, zum Beispiel.
Jemand in der Gruppe hat Kreuzpantelis gesagt, kann man auch haben, wenn man früher öfters
vor der Kreuzpantelision hatte zum Beispiel, kann man auch mal durch mehr Überlastung auch
eine, ohne Traumatik eine Rupatur haben, vor der Kreuzpantelision. Ist sehr selten, aber kann man
das häufig ohne Trauma, ist es ein junger Mensch, ohne Trauma ist ein Miniskussproblem, weil es auch
medial ist. Und ein älterer Mensch würde man eher als erstes als eine beginnende Arthrose oder eine
Arthrose denken. Ja, eine Arthrose. Normalerweise, ich glaube die Kreuzpantelis, der Patient kommt
mit. Ja, ich spiele, ich habe Fußball gespielt, dann ich habe ein Geräusch gehört, an den ich hier
sage, ich glaube. Ja. Und, sollten wir? Traumatisch gerissen ist es so, aber stellt sich vor,
Sie haben vor ein paar Jahren zwei, drei Mal Verletzungen gehabt. Es ist nicht ganz gerissen,
sagen wir mal 80, 90 Prozent gerissen. Und jetzt beim Gestern beim Fußballspiel ist nur noch
der letzte 10 Prozent gerissen, kann ja sein. Also eine chronische Rupatur, tut nicht unbedingt sehr wie.
Theoretisch, praktisch ist es eher, was Sie sagen. Weil jemand in die Gruppe geschrieben hat,
Kreuzpantelis, aber die ist ja arthraumatisch, also chronisch-degenerativ Veränderung und
dann dadurch bedingt vielleicht eine Rupatur. Wie kann ich diese Frage stellen?
Wie? Wenn Sie diese Probleme bekommen haben, was haben Sie gemacht? Wie kann ich diese Frage stellen,
besser als das? Nochmal, habe ich nicht verstanden. Sie haben ja die Frage zwar gestellt und deswegen
haben Sie sich das gemerkt. Was haben Sie gemacht, wenn die Schmerzen aufgetreten sind?
Ist das richtige Verwendung oder? Was haben Sie gemacht, als die Schmerzen anfingen oder
auftraten? Nichts, Medikamente eingenommen, gekühlt vielleicht. Er hat, aber man kann
kühlen, Medikamente einnehmen oder zum Arzt gehen, Hausarzt gehen und er hat nichts festgestellt.
Ja, ich glaube, ich kann die, waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt fragen?
Ja, aber ich war nicht beim anderen Arzt.
Menis für süktisch, dann?
Genau, man kann, wenn man nicht genau weiß, was es ist, kann man auch Meniskus lesion sagen,
es ist sehr generell.
Ödem, vielleicht?
Ja, genau, es kann auch eine Überlastung des Knochens gewesen sein, ein Wohnbruch,
ein Odem des medialen Femurkondulis sein zum Beispiel oder der Tibia Plateau sein, das ist
eine Differenzialdiagnose, was Sie gesagt haben, das stimmt.
Krellung oder so?
Es kann auch ein Reizzustand des medialen Kollateralbandes sein, Kapselbandentzündung sein, also
ein Reizzustand sein.
Oder nur eine Symptome der Patiente hat gesagt, gehen, schmerzen, ein Kilometer.
Ja, wenn er lange gelaufen ist, also bei deutlicher Belastung, dann müssen wir
erst mal Meniskus lesion oder?
Ja, kann man sagen, bei Wohnbruch oder Knochenödem würde er nach zwei, drei Meter
schon Schmerzen haben oder direkt haben.
Und es gibt ein Gefühl, ich glaube, ich trete auf einem Loch oder?
Ich kann jetzt sagen.
Ja, in einem Loch oder in eine Leere?
Ja, ja.
Auf eine Leere.
In einer Leere.
Man trete auf eine Leere.
Ja, das war es, ich glaube.
Proximale Tibia Sprung, was meinen Sie mit Tibia Sprung?
Irgendjemand hat etwas, Tibia Sprung beschrieben, habe ich nicht verstanden,
kenne ich nicht diesen Wort?
Ich habe auch eine Proximale Tibia Sprung, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, dass ich alles weiß, aber ich habe es mir nicht bekannt.
Oder wollte etwas besonders schieben bei einem Sprung?
Nein, das heißt Tibia.
Okay, weiß ich nicht, weiter.
Es gibt Therapie und sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Schlage ich die Folgen der Therapie vor.
Moment, Moment.
Ja, genau.
Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose, dass der Knie mediale Gonalgie hat
und mit Verdachtdiagnose-Lision.
Wie würden Sie weiter vorgehen?
Als erstes, Massdame, würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ausführlich körperlich, das ist immer schön,
ausführlich körperlich untersuchen.
Ausführlich, ich würde eine...
Was bedeutet das?
Ausführlich, das heißt sehr genau, sehr intensiv.
Nein, ich glaube die betropfene Stelle, die beide Stelle kann.
Ausführlich, ich sage nicht komplett, ich sage nicht eine komplette körperliche.
Sondern eine ausführliche heißt, ich würde mich sehr ausführlich
mit dem Kniegelenk beschäftigen.
Ich kann einmal sagen, ich habe nur das Kniegelenk hinter mir bewegt.
Ich habe gedrückt, das tut es weh, aber ich kann auch sagen,
ich habe einen Miniskustest gemacht, ich habe eine Patella-Feschiebetest gemacht,
ich habe... das ist eine ausführliche Untersuchung über das Knie.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich detailliert, ja, kann man auch sagen,
eine detaillierte Untersuchung.
Deswegen hört es, wenn man sagt, ich...
Zuerst würde ich eine ausführliche Untersuchung des Schülern sozusagen.
Dann kann ich Blut abnehmen, um die Erisipel auszuschließen,
vielleicht wegen Überwärmung.
Ja, wegen Überwärmung.
Einfach, ich würde nicht sagen Erisipel, dann kommt man...
Einfach erstmal mit kleinen Häpfchen.
Ich würde Labor abnehmen wegen der Überwärmung,
ob Entzündungsparameter erhöht sind, fertig.
Ja, okay.
Wenn ich jetzt fragen würde, an welcher Entzündungsparameter denken Sie,
jetzt können Sie antworten.
ZR-Aktivprotein, CRP,
und PSG, Brutik und Geschehwindigkeit und Prokastonin,
aber ich glaube, es ist nicht nötig.
Ne, Prokastonin ist nicht so eine Brutipedie,
also es ist ein LTH,
Lackdruck, Genass.
Ganz einfach, denken Sie ganz...
Die Schirurgen denken,
kleines Blutbild,
was ist da wichtigste Parameter,
kleines Blutbild?
Kleines Blutbild, undifferant.
Es gibt nur drei Parameter, die uns interessieren,
eigentlich CRP, Leukoziden
und eventuell PSG.
Ja, mehr nicht.
Wenn wir diese Patienten...
Wir sind nicht sehr kompliziert, wir sind einfach.
Okay.
Ja, ich mag Orthopädie, aber...
Vielleicht wollen wir diese Patienten operieren?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
Sie haben erst mal ausführlich untersucht,
Sie haben ein Labor abgenommen?
Ich meinte, die war bei Labor abgenommen.
Achso, nein, nein, nein,
Entschuldigung, nochmals, sagen Sie noch mal Ihre Aussage.
Wenn wir diese Patienten operieren,
operieren, operieren, operieren, operieren, operieren, operieren,
als präoperative Vorbereitung,
kann man auch...
Präoperative Vorbereitung können wir machen?
Bei Miniskus lesion machen wir keine Notfalloperation.
Auch wenn wir sagen, es geht nicht um Leben,
kann man morgen übermorgen nächste Woche machen.
Sie haben recht.
Das heißt, nicht so viele denken einfach nur kurz wie bündig.
Aber wichtig ist zum Beispiel, Sie haben körperlich untersucht,
Sie haben Labor abgenommen, muss man nicht, aber...
Röntgen veranlassen.
Genau, Röntgen veranlassen.
Wie würde diese Röntgenaufnahme die Anforderung,
wenn Sie dem Radiologen schreiben?
Ja, zwei Ebenen, zwei Ebenen, Kniegelenk.
Ja, genau, das hier, jetzt kommt es langsam, das stimmt schon.
Jetzt noch mal einen neuen Satz, ich würde...
Ich würde in zwei Ebenen Kniegelenk röntgen veranlassen.
Genau, ich würde erst, ich würde ein röntgendes rechten Kniegelenk
in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Aber sollen wir die beide Kniegelenk, oder nur eine?
Nein, hat nur rechts Problem.
Warum sollen wir röntgenstrahlen Belastung machen für links?
Und auf der Pädie schauen, ich glaube, die beiden, um zu vergleichen.
Ich glaube, sie wissen besser, als ich.
Vergleichen, es geht nicht um irgendwelche angeborene Krankheiten
oder Hüftysplasien oder irgendwas, sondern es geht um eine lokale Beschwerde
und deswegen macht man nur eine Seite.
Ich mache keine beinlängen Unterschiedsmessung oder irgendwas.
Das ist eine sehr spezielle, orthobidische Fragestellung.
Eigentlich röntgen, merken Sie sich bitte,
wenn Sie dem Radiologen handschriftlich, heutzutage klickt man das,
meistens im Büro, aber früher haben wir das handschriftlich geschrieben.
Erbitte röntgen, Kniegelenk rechts in zwei Ebenen, zum Beispiel.
Röntgen, Halsvibelsäule in zwei Ebenen,
Röntgen, Sprunggelenk in zwei Ebenen, immer dasselbe, röntgen, Hüfte in zwei Ebenen.
Gegeben, falls CT, ich glaube.
Moment, falls, warum würden Sie röntgen, der hat ja keinen Trauma gehabt.
Was wollen Sie damit bezwecken?
Wir können die...
Das ist der Nachteil, das war auch komplizierter bisschen.
Warum, was ist der Vor- und Nachteil eines Röntgens?
Vorteil, wir können...
oder röntgen kann den Knochen besser aufzeichen.
Darstellen?
Darstellen, oder...
Weichtgewebe, weichtgewebe kann röntgen, nicht sehr gut...
Kann nicht sehr gut dargestellt werden.
Dargestellt werden, ja.
Aber ein weiterer Hauptnachteil ist, das Röntgen, was ist?
Das ist ein Drang, das Röntgen, das Röntgen, das Röntgen, das Röntgen, das Röntgen,
hat und dessen Folgen schlimm sein könnte.
Deswegen machen wir, wir schonen, zu röntgen.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, ich möchte röntgen.
Da muss man die Fragen abwägen, warum möchten Sie röntgen, um etwas auszuschließen.
Sie haben ja Miniskuls verdacht, Miniskuls ist kein Knochen.
Also, Miniskuls muss man nicht röntgen, röntgen.
Aber vielleicht wollen Sie doch röntgen, warum, frage ich.
Wir können beurteilen, dass die wischenden Knochen, aber wir können es...
Gelenkspalt?
Ja, Gelenkspalt, beurteilen, oder wir können...
1, Nummer 1, Nummer 2, was haben wir vorhin gesagt, ist sehr selten.
Was können wir ausschließen? Das ist keine pathologische Fraktur.
Ja.
Das haben wir auch ausschließen.
Ja, sobald ich es geschrieben habe.
Alles gut.
Und ich würde dieser Patient die folgende vorschlagen.
Moment, nicht vorschlagen, wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Welche Maßnahmen würden Sie weiter empfehlen?
Eine bildgebende Maßnahme würden Sie empfehlen?
Damit man den Miniskuls darstellen kann, gibt es eine bestimmte Besonderung?
Normalerweise gibt es...
Artroskopie, aber...
Artroskopie ist keine bildgebende Verfalle, ist auch, ja, aber nicht richtig.
MRT auch um Miniskuls ausschließen.
MRT ist nicht MRI, sondern wir sind in Deutschland.
MRT ist für diejenigen, die das geschrieben haben.
Ich bin ein Kennsteller.
Kennsteller, genau.
Was ist der Vorteil von MRT?
MRT mit MRT kann die WeihGB besorgen und...
ohne Schütterung.
Genau. Was ist der Vorteil von MRT?
Was ist der Nachteil von MRT?
Es dauert ca. 30 Minuten.
Der Patient muss...
Was würde ich sagen?
Der Patient muss flach liegen und es gibt in die Röhre viele Geräusche.
Der Patient hat ein Klostropopie.
Genau. Was ist aber...
Was ist noch ein... das stimmt schon.
Und was ist noch ein Nachteil? Hat jemand geschrieben?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ah, na zäh...
Es ist teuer und...
Ich komme aus Kaiser, deswegen... ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, hier in Deutschland ist es teuer.
Das ist teuer.
In der Türkei im Vergleich zu Deutschland, in Türkei ist es günstig.
Ja, genau.
100 Euro, aber hier kostet es so...
wenn man privat machen möchte, um die 400 bis 600 Euro durchnimmt.
Es gibt viele Patienten in der Türkei, die uns gekommen sind.
Ich möchte eine MRT veranlassen.
Worin bewerbe ich?
Ja, man kann ja alles haben wollen.
Aber man kriegt auch in Deutschland nicht unbedingt schnelle Termine.
Wenn Sie in Krankenhaus sind, können Sie nicht sagen,
wir machen mal eine MRT in der Notfallamplanz.
Sondern man empfehlt, was Sie gleich sagen werden, die Therapien.
Man empfehlt etwas und empfehlt auch,
dass man bei beschwerter Persistenz, bei anhaltenden Beschwerden,
dass man eine MRT machen sollte.
Zum Beispiel steht der meistens in den Briefen drinnen.
Ich empfehle...
Und wenn bei beschwerter Persistenz empfehle ich
Durchführung eines MRT-Rechtenkniegelinkes, zum Beispiel würde heißen.
Aber in den Krankenhäusern, wenn eine größere Sache,
zum Beispiel ein Schlaganfall hat,
wenn man da ein MRT haben will, dann kriegt man dann schon einen.
Da geht es ja um Zeitgewinnen.
Aber die orthopedischen, umfalschürogischen Sachen
ist äußerst selten.
Das hat Verständnis.
Es wird zum Beispiel sein, wenn jemand einen Bandscheinvorfall hat
und hat eine Paräse.
Da ist die Entscheidung, dass er nicht mehr einbricht.
Kommt es von dieser Bandschein,
oder nicht diese Fußäperparäse zum Beispiel?
Da muss man schnell reagieren.
Es wird nicht gleich Notfall ein bisschen gemacht,
aber es wird Zeitgange gemacht.
Also in einem oder zwei Tagen.
Aber es ist nicht wie ein Herzenpack.
Man muss gleich zack, zack, zack machen.
Orthopedischen und verschürogens sind immer die Letzten im Krankenhaus,
die man so dranlässt.
Weil es nicht in mein Leben geht.
Oder in ein Organ vielleicht.
Gut, wir haben Röpgen durchgeführt.
Was haben Sie?
Was kann man in einem Röntgen erkennen?
Sie haben vorhin gesagt, zum Beispiel,
wie weit der Gelenkspalt ist.
Eine Fraktur vorhanden ist.
Oder eine Pathologie,
irgendeine Pathologie vorhanden ist.
Was kann man noch im Kniegelenk erkennen?
Pehlstellung.
Könnte man auch theoretisch.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Da gibt es nicht vieles im Kniegelenk.
Therapie.
Genau.
Wir haben eine Fraktur ausgeschlossen
durch eine Röntgenuntersuchung.
Ja.
Was von unseren Diagnosen?
Menüstens.
Genau.
Der Patient ist jüngerem.
Ich würde die Folgen der MF-Fäilen
gibt es Knieband.
Oder
die Bandage.
Die Bandage.
Bandage.
Es gibt eine Bandage und Orteuse.
Orteuse.
Orteuse ist ein bisschen gestellt.
Mit Rahmen.
Das muss man nicht gleich machen.
Ich würde das mit einem Volter den Salvenverband versorgen.
Aber Diplofenac.
Dann gibt es auch Ibuprofenesalve.
Gut aufgepasst.
Vielen Dank.